wer bei shampoo
jede seite
er weiß schon heute wohlgemuth sind
immer wieder alles neu beginnt
hier mit leichtem gepäck wir fahren
jetzt in die ukraine sie steht zum
naturschutz
1200 m dann machen wir da führt apple
ich werde unsere redakteurinnen und von
der deutschen welle dabei cherry tree
ist auch noch gewalt um die tour ist zu
keiner gekommen in der ukraine 28
stunden fahrt
gestern haben wir die philharmonie
gesehen heute wären wir dort spielen
fantastisch
wir haben gestern fantastisches konzert
gespielt und jetzt gehen wir in die
schule und werden dort unterricht halten
hip hop deutschunterricht wir sind
angekommen schule nummer fünf mit
erweiterten deutschunterricht geplant
mit 24 bis 25 schüler jetzt in salz 70
die mit unserem workshop machen
wir sind die musiker die ihr seht timmy
hat seine gitarre dabei könnten sie mal
aus natürlich an meinen kleinen sohn
vorbereitet wir können so etwas gruppen
oder wir machen ernst
von c
recht streng und steinbeck
das alles steht
unter
zeitung vom platz wir sind einfach 6
eine band aus münchen wissen was wir
machen
es gefällt
die stimmung spaß
es gefällt mir wenn ich diese
das
ich liege laut
stelle
wir sind jetzt auf dem weg nach 6 uhr
zwar deutschland es war hammergeil die
stimmung war der wahnsinn die ukraine
ist toll danke an alle fans auf welchem
vorgehen oft immer ihr euch umtreibt
zeigt uns das hilft uns dass wir
wiederkommen und wir kommen gerne wieder